une semaine après in le va et vient est
incessant secouriste est bénévoles
rapatrie toujours les insulaires dans
leurs embarcations des personnes âgées
et des familles qui reviennent du Nil
coupée du monde
c'était terrifiant nous confie cette
sinistrie qui était sur Pineland avec
son petit-fils lorsque l'ouragan a
frappé
un gilet de sauvetage j'avais une balise
de localisation dans une main et un
chapelet dans l'autre par contre cet
autre insulaire qui a passé six heures
au cœur de la tempête
pendant que certains sont soulagés
d’enfin retrouver leurs proches sur la
terre ferme
d'autres essaient de regagner l'île
grâce à l'aide de bons samaritains
chaque jour Erens
lui et son épouse Jamie mettent leur
barge au service des insulaires qui ont
besoin de s'approvisionner
le trajet prend une trentaine de minutes
tout au long on constate l'ampleur des
dégâts les maisons les petits
restaurants rien n'a été épargné
le retour sur l'île est d'où amer pour
le couple la dévastation leur brise le
cœur
mais Hélène et Jamie sont contents de
retrouver des visages familiers
je suis attaché à cette communauté je
veux aider mes voisins et mes amis
explique un pompier père de deux enfants
et des pour se tenir
occupé et ne pas céder ou désespoir
plus au nord mais une légère déviation
de sa trajectoire a pris les résidents
de Pineland par surprise et leur compter
attarder à ordonner l'évacuation
les insulaires sont depuis largement
laissés à eux-mêmes sans électricité eau
potable ou connexion cellulaire avec
seulement une poignée de policiers sur
une des plus grandes îles de la Floride
les résidents organisent donc des
patrouilles citoyennes maintenant que la
tempête est passée c'est le pillage qui
les inquiète
il y a quelques minutes on a entendu des
coups de feu raconte cette ancien
militaire venue apporter de l'aide aussi
dans ce quartier pas de coups de feu ou
de bruit de génératrices mais lourd
silence et quelques indices de la vie
paisible que les résidents y menaient il
y a à peine une semaine
ce secteur est toujours très bien
entretenu explique Jamie qui en profite
pour jeter un œil sur la maison de ses
voisins pistolet à la ceinture en dépit
de la destruction et de l'insécurité la
mère de famille ne quittera pas son île
17h approche et la barge doit rentrer à
Keep Cool avant la tombée de la nuit de
nouveau passagers charge leurs valises
sur le bateau les derniers biens qu'ils
ont pu récupérer de leur maison
détruites et inondées
[Musique]
même si tout est détruit
un sentiment que partage ses compagnons
qui trouvent leur réconfort dans
l'entraide et la générosité
quand vient le temps de toucher terre
les insulaires se disent au revoir
pour essayer de sauver leur coin de
paradis toujours couper du monde